[Musique]
savez vous que 46 % des touristes se
concentrent dans dix destinations
ça paraît à peine étonnant mais en fait
c'est dramatique car ça signifie que
nous nous contentons de répéter ce que
les autres font cantonné dans les
prestations touristiques qu'on nous
impose et que nous fermons les yeux et
les oreilles à ce que le reste du monde
a à nous dire et à nous montrer moi je
pense que nous ne va pas toujours une
bonne conception de ce qu'est le voyage
qu'on considère trop souvent comme une
sorte de récompense qui nous est dû et
dont on exige beaucoup de choses
avouons le on préfère qu'ils soient sans
accroc sans trop de difficulté bien
balisé on y optimise son temps pour
surtout ne pas en perdre
koch les cases ou fait les pays mais à
vouloir tout faire et s'est vite on
s'éloigne des aspérités du monde des
histoires qu'il y ait font les peuples
manque l'essentiel le voyage n'est pas
un produit de consommation
c'est une expérience bien humaine qui
nous parle de notre présence au monde
elle nous parle de nous la tante la peur
l'ennui les difficultés et l'inconnu
sont des valeurs positives dans la vie
et à plus forte raison dans le voyage
elles sont le fondement de notre
évolution
les offres beaucoup en contre partie ils
font jouer nos facultés d'adaptation
penser à l'apprentissage d'une langue
étrangère d'un instrument de musique à
la pratique du sport ou celle de l'amour
non rien d'acquis et se gagne dans
l'effort
alors les fort justement
en 2016 j'ai 24 ans je décide de
rejoindre pékin depuis paris ap c'est
pourquoi alors eh bien parce que la
chine ne m'attirait pas du tout j'étais
plein de préjugés j'ai voulu savoir
pourquoi je décide donc d'y aller à pied
pour avoir le temps de me faire au pays
pour appréhender le climat la géographie
les fuseaux horaires plutôt que d'y
atterrir sans ménagement j'avais envie
d'avoir une vision globale du pays
connaître l'histoire qui lie la chine
aux pays qui l'entourent voir les yeux
des russes se brider en sibérie
orientale et devenir des mongols dans
l'histoire mende réduite aux chinois
j'avais ainsi des éléments pour mieux
comprendre cette étrange civilisation
bonjour pas une grande fan de ce pays au
moins je sais pourquoi
et mieux se comprendre est un premier
pas pour mieux s'entendre
je pense que c'est un peu de ça dont il
s'agit d'un voyage si on devait y
trouver un sens
alors bien sûr ça demande un effort en
mongolie j'ai dû traiter avec des gens
qui ne connaissait pas ni la religion
cathodique ni paris n'avaient jamais
entendu parler de mon prénom
il ne connaissait pas les mots yes ou no
ou stop ou communiquer c'est pas évident
je me suis retrouvé dans des situations
plutôt improbable j'ai dû faire des
mines des dessins finalement tout ce qui
nous liait était notre appartenance
commune à l'espèce humaine mais ça a
toujours suffi pour que je trouve au
moins un toit de l'eau et même de
l'amitié
alors il faut réapprendre à faire
confiance à de parfaits inconnus
les locaux et les autochtones sont les
mieux placés pour vous aider car ce sont
ceux qui connaissent le mieux les
territoires dans lesquels ils vivent
aussi j'aime dire que nous nous
ressemblons tous au fond car nous avons
tous les mêmes besoins
dormir sous un toit manger chaud faire
l'amour et à traîner ce qui change c'est
l'architecturé des maisons menu dans
l'assiette les rituels amoureux c'est
tout ça vaut donc le coup de lâcher
prise pour s'ouvrir au trésor de vix qui
nous entoure et des trésors
j'en ai amassé pas mal lors de mon
expédition paris new york sans avion à
une vie rock sans avion je vous explique
chez moi j'ai un planisphère qui montre
clairement que le continent américain et
le continent asiatique sont en fait à
peine séparée par une bande de mer de 70
km le détroit de béring
alors je me suis dit que ça pouvait être
marrant de faire comme nos ancêtres
ils sont sortis d'afrique il ya 175
mille ans et qui ont peuplé le continent
américain en traversant ce détroit quand
il était glacée il s'agissait donc d'un
défi technique bien sûr mais surtout
d'un défi humain sur cette expédition
je décide de me laisser porter par le
libre arbitre le temps qu'un peu de
magie opère puisqu'on parle de magie
natalia gelé rencontré dans un train qui
m'emmenait à kiev quand elle a su que
j'étais française elle a appelé toutes
ses amis francophones qui ont joué les
traducteurs intermédiaires et leur dit
de me dire que l mais bergeret à kiev
chez elle j'ai passé quelques jours dans
sa ville colada elle m'a emmené
absolument partout chez elle dans la
banlieue pauvre
j'ai été choyé ça me préparer à manger
comme une maman elle m'a donné des
crèmes pour les mains les pieds les
ongles on m'a préparé l'eau de la douche
en chauffant au poil il m'a même proposé
d'aller dormir ailleurs pour que je sois
tranquille
elle m'a préparé des petits pain au four
quand il a fallu partir et m'a
accompagné jusque dans le wagon qui
m'emmenait à possible j'ai encore dans
la bouche le goût de ces petits pains et
quelques nouvelles des leçons whatsapp
vitaly d'italie m'a prise en stop sur
une route de sibérie pensons qu'à me ce
qui sur papier n'a rien de très
rassurant mais il m'a dit qu'il allait
marier sa fille avait dit vostok
alors j'ai eu confiance et je suis monté
on a passé quatre jours en 4000
kilomètres durant lesquelles il a tenu à
me traiter comme une princesse le payer
absolument tout chaque repas chaque
douche chaque machine m'a fait un petit
lit dans le fond de son camion il allait
même me cueillir des baies sur le bord
de la route
notre relation était surfaite de silence
pour des questions de langue maman mais
il a quand même tenu à me partager un
secret avant il avait beaucoup d'argent
il était maître de plusieurs entreprises
pas mettre des chefs de plusieurs
entreprises il a voulu être maître de
son temps et il a trouvé sa liberté au
volant de son camion sur les longues
routes de 6 pm aujourd'hui il prend
encore de mes nouvelles
et ils m'ont envoyé des photos du
mariage de sa fille johnny c'est une
nuit au beau milieu du canada dans un
bus que je rencontre cette vieille dame
de 81 ans
c'est une ans
une fille de la ferme qui a grandi avec
onze frères et soeurs dans la région du
saskatchewan elle me parle de ses
parents venus de scandinavie des indiens
de la réserve près de laquelle il vivait
de patin à glace au clair de lune d'une
cabane près d'un lac et des ours qu'elle
rencontrait à vélo elle me parle d'amour
et des anges qui me protège rond sur les
derniers kilomètres de mon voyage
john restera comme un moment de poésie
de mon voyage
le lendemain
j'arrive à calgary et je visite un musée
qui est consacré aux natifs de la région
et blackfoot oui les indiens d'amérique
et du canada je lis qu'il est un
festival auquel les non natifs peuvent
assister ou pas wall revenons un instant
sur cette notion de non natifs 18 en
fait les non autochtones
on peut plus vraiment dire des canadiens
et des américains qui sont des immigrés
ou des colons et pourtant il n'existe
pas de termes pour désigner ceux qui
sont arrivés juste après imaginons qu'un
tel terme existent en france
cela éviterait peut-être d'essentialiser
les nouveaux français alors religion ou
alors couleur de peau de manière
aléatoire ou même de ça la différence
entre un expat ou un émigré en nouvelle
zélande il ya le joli terme de papier à
pour désigner ceux qui ne sont pas des
maoris montre f2 politique revenons-en
ou pas wall le palois c'est une fête qui
est un ensemble de célébration et de
représentation chantante et dansante des
tribus locales
c'est la seule qui soit ouverte à ceux
qui n'appartiennent pas à leur tribu
elles ont été traumatisés par les
persécutions et les oppressions qu'ils
ont subies par les colons au 10ème
siècle
je décide donc de m'incruster dernier
pas aux arabes de la région
je pars en stop je trouve un endroit où
dormir au débotté
j'arrive dans un endroit hors du monde
où tous les indiens sont habillés comme
il l'était avant d'être américanisé je
passe la journée
émerveillés par les chants brut est
assourdissant des indiens envoûter par
les battements de tambour sacré lordon
furieuse interminables et les
processions intertribales par centaines
je goûte du béluga sécher du saumon fumé
sont sucrés aussi de la vienne de la
viande de renne et de caribous je danse
avec des inuits et je dispute avec des
membres de la tribu athabaskan je repars
enchanté d'avoir une des images de ce
que je n'avais vu que dans les bd et
surtout une meilleure idée de ce que
c'est qu'être indiens d'amérique au
21ème siècle
vitaly et natalia m'ont marqué par leurs
dons d'abnégation et la confiance qu'ils
ont su m'inspirer dans des conditions
que ça n'avait rien d'évident
john et les indiens ont nourri mon
imaginaire d'image extraordinaire ils
m'ont ouvert des fenêtres sur le monde
et j'aime savoir que j'ai touché du
doigt des histoires mythiques
je raconterai à mes enfants et que je
peux raconter aujourd'hui les inuits eux
ont chamboulé
je parle là de gens où qu'ils le monde
entier a un rôle est une figure
différentes
je vais vous donner seulement un aperçu
de leurs pratiques parce qu'il me
faudrait une vie pour pour leur parler
d'eux dans leur tribu simon donne le nom
de son grand-père à une petite fille qui
naît elle récupère à un genre et une
identité masculin cette ambiguïté du
genre peut aller jusqu au
travestissement
elle sera initié à la chasse et à la
manipulation d'outils d'hommes il ya
aussi leur rapport à la nature dont
chaque élément est pourvu d'une âme le
vent les pierres et les animaux bien
entendu c'est un métal égal de la leur
et ils peuvent renoncer à chasser un
phoque
par exemple si l'un des chasseurs voit
dans ses yeux ceux de son
arrière-grand-mère
ils nourrissent ce corps et et le veille
aussi pour le remercier de son don de
nourriture
je trouve
et qu'il existe des civilisations qui
ont des interprétations totalement
différentes des nôtres on peut penser
que notre médecine notre culture nos
structures économiques et sociales sont
tout à fait légitimes et coule de source
et pourtant il existe des gens qui ne
comprendrait ce moment rien à notre
façon de faire vous trouvez pas ça
génial vous de pouvoir remettre en
question même votre vision du vent c'est
terriblement excitant
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout
remettre en cause ou tout nié en bloc
mais c'est juste une occasion très rare
de se retourner le cerveau et d'agrandir
le champ des possibles si j'ai voulu
éviter le choc des cultures en voyageant
lentement je n'ai en revanche rien pu
faire contre le choc des rencontres en
fait je suis même devenu accro et
aujourd'hui je suis dans la recherche en
anthropologie pour bien entretenir ce
choc être constamment chamboulé et
regarder le monde à l'envers
pas de côté bien sûr je ne dis pas qu'il
faut qu'on se mettre tous à la new york
à pied mais soyons plus attentifs et
courageux osent ont davantage rassembler
les corps et les énergies les visions et
les émotions pour avancer vers nos buts
comment partir sur le chemin des hommes
c'est faire le choix de cette délaissé
de son nom de sa réputation et de ses
outils ses se décentrer de soi pour
revenir à hauteur d'homme et s'offrir le
cadeau de la rencontre la plus
extraordinaire est la plus banale celle
de ses exotiques semblables merci
[Applaudissements]